pour
eh bien bon soir l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs ce soir
sur diagonale le bienvenu avec le grand
maître international et loire l'ange
conscience les fans alors commence à
valoir bonne semaine ça va semaine
d'entraînement comme comme d'habitude en
fait j'ai joué un petit tournoi ce week
end à fourmies ça n'a pas très bien
marché où elle tombera donc fourmille tu
peux nous rappeler où s'est noyé dans le
nord c'est
c'est dans le nord en fait tout
simplement c'est une toute petite ville
c'était un tournoi sur trois jours donc
il y avait une dizaine de grands maîtres
assez difficile parce que beaucoup de
partis voyez ce jour c'est en fait une
sorte de marathon puisqu'on joue six
parties longues en trois jours c'est à
dire deux parties par jour qui peuvent
durer jusqu'à six heures
donc ça fait des journées de 12 heures
c'est long ça demande une bonne forme
physique et donc à ce jeu là c'est
l'israélien golstein qui a gagné le
tournoi
voilà pour ce donc ce tournoi un
français tendent aux français voilà
l'actualité internationale cette semaine
c'est évidemment la suite et la fin du
tournage de sarajevo
alors la semaine dernière on a oublié de
vous annoncer une nouvelle aussi
importante puisque le grand maître
international lembit hall est décédé et
loi je crois que tu le connaissais tu
peux peut-être vous parler de ceux de ce
grand maître wyoming
oui en fait je ne connaissais un petit
peu il était venu au championnat de
paris où un tournoi en région parisienne
il ya assez longtemps j'avais profité de
l'occasion pour m'entraîner un peu avec
lui donc il avait une très grosse
préparation dans les ouvertures il
maîtrise bien son sujet c'est un joueur
très fort mais qu'avec un des problèmes
psychologiques et donc ça s'est terminé
un peu tragiquement voilà donc on n'est
qu'un petit peu en deuil puisque donc
c'est un grand maître ont connu reconnu
et et qui avait fait dix ans on parlait
de lui et qui avaient fait de très
belles parties jusqu'à donc ce jour
tragique donc décédé la semaine et
revient voilà donc tournoi de sarajevo
donc la semaine dernière nous annoncions
donc enfin de vous avions commenté
une partie de kasparov la partie
kasparov contre short et puis donc la
belle prestation on est en train de
commenter la belle prestation de
alexander morozevich la révélation de
l'année
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine donc la fameuse partie
kasparov morose et vite il ya eu lieu
mardi dernier et auparavant donc qu'est
ce qui s'était passé exactement à ce
tournoi loi jusqu'à mardi donc bec
kasparov a continué de dominer ce qui
s'est passé dans le tournoi c'est que
finalement c'est les joueurs qu'on
attendait pas trop qui se sont réveillés
en fin de fin de tableau comme barrière
donc qui avait terminé solidement en
gagnant ces dernières parties borusewicz
par contre donc ce qu'on attendait il a
il a craqué il a complètement craqué il
jouer donc il a joué contre kasparov cri
contre bas relief et il a perdu ses deux
parties voilà que deux défaites
d'affilée dans le tournoi
ça s'est ressenti un peu sur son sort
sans résultat final il a craqué
partiellement puisqu'il a perdu que ces
deux partis
il fait quand même un tournoi
relativement honorable il a fini par
gagner une ronde
il confirme quand même son rang de
numéro 5 mondial
on est définitivement convaincu qu'il
n'est pas là par hasard ah oui tout à
fait il a fait une très belle prestation
dans ce tournoi ça c'est indiscutable il
à son départ canon avec trois signés sur
cinq
bon alors effectivement peut-être qu'il
lui manquait un peu d'expérience
après sa défaite contre kasparov finesse
pris une fessée fait infligé une
nouvelle défaite dans la foulée disons
donc ça c'est ceux des petits défauts en
fait que qui doit pouvoir rectifier
assez facilement il faut dire aussi
qu'il a pas beaucoup de pratique à ce
niveau là donc sur le moment il s'est
peut-être un peu laissé aller je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé dans sa tête et
donc il a perdu deux parties de suite ce
qui est considérable quand même voilà
donc on rappelle les faits me revitch
fait une année 98 exceptionnel ils
viennent tous les tournois auxquels il
participe avec des scores fabuleux et
donc il arrive numéro 5 mondial et en
fait on attendait vraiment sa prestation
dans un tournoi du top niveau mondial
avec les dix meilleurs joueurs du monde
c'était le cas sarajevo il craque un
petit peu disons en milieu de tournoi
mais quand même il finit tourna on en
parlera évidemment après en fin
d'émission puisqu'on va garder un
semblant de suspense il s'est quand même
donc un très beau tournoi donkey ceci se
passe qu'apprécier de défaite on
constate que les deux véritables
concurrents de kasparov sur le tournoi
ce n'est pas tellement au civisme et
plus tôt
barrière et shirov qui talonne kasparov
l'écho quant à lui fait une prestation
pas mauvaise non plus mais moyenne ils
n'arrivent pas à gagner deux parties en
fait ils arrivent à un peu équilibré son
jeu mais il n'a pas réussi à percer le
mur entre guillemets et donc d'ailleurs
il fit une partie nulle contre kasparov
n'arrive pas à sortir quelque chose pour
le battre mais bon il est quand même il
tient le choc
oui c'est sa basse et c'est ce qu'on
avait dit sur peter dès qu il est en
quête d'une victoire de toute façon dans
ces tournois
il cherche à gagner des parties et
apparemment ils arrivent pas
complètement à se libérer de son ancien
style de jeu et respect à ses
conservateurs en tout cas au niveau des
résultats
maintenant ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
ces partis sont quand même beaucoup plus
sportive
enfin le sportif beaucoup plus fun
qu'avant c'est à dire qu'ils jouent aux
quatre maintenant il attaque il cherche
quand même de l'initiative ça se sent on
sent qu'il cherche quelque chose en ce
moment qui n'arrivent pas à trouver pour
l'instant mais il a 19 ans il met encore
très jeune il ya encore très jeune voilà
donc kasparov talonné en fait ces deux
véritables concurrents talonné par bas
relief et alexei shirov qui donc depuis
bordeaux n'avait pas fait tournoi le
tournoi de bordeaux dont gagné par les
causes temps et là il confirme un bon
retour puisqu'il ne finalement il y perd
mon parti donc contre
la partie qui perd contre je sais plus
oublier contre qui perd une partie dans
le tournoi je sais plus je sais pas si
on a le classement peut-être eloi pour
retrouver le gain donc je sais plus je
sais plus non plus contre qui on est
mort on évite justement par la morose
est vite balayée bachir voilà dans une
défense petrov voilà tout à fait légale
par les spécialistes on en avait parlé
la dernière fois donc on peut rappeler
un peu ce qu'on a dit sur cette partie
c'était la fameuse anecdote avec boris
gelfand qui a annoncé que morose et
beach était moins bien alors qu'en fait
on avait pensé tout le monde par tout le
monde pensait qu'il était mieux du début
à la fin parce qu'il avait besoin de
plus puisqu'il allie d'après un pion une
partie qui avait l'air très propre ouais
donc analyse à venir donc seules des
fêtes de schirrhoffen à ce tournoi
donc si hrw confirment un bon retour
talonne kasparov avec bas relief qu'un
petit peu la surprise de ce tournoi la
véritable surprise avec confirmation de
nos rosés leach bon tournoi de l'écho et
bas relief qui qui fait un petit peu la
surprise puisque on le disait l'un des
rares fois aussi c'est un joueur qui
n'est pas souvent vie invité dans les
tournois du top mondial du fait qu'il y
ait russe et qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de
russes d'invités que pour avoir
plusieurs nationalités les organisateurs
préfèrent évidemment invité plusieurs
nationalités dans un même dans un même
tournoi
oui donc barria il a en fait il n'a pas
fait un tournoi flamboyant il a pas il
n'a pas fait de miracle simplement il a
il a su saisir saisir sa chance dans
chaque partie c'est à dire chaque fois
que l'occasion s'est présentée il était
là et il a donc marqué le point
donc il n'a pas perdu deux parties c'est
ça qu'on peut remarquer c'est je pense
le sol avec des ris kasparov à ne pas
avoir perdu en lice essarts exactement
donc
tournoi tu en as assez bien géré et
finalement par barrière alors il réagit
me tiens monde il était quand même un
demi point de garry kasparov voilà
vraiment opposition d'embuscades donc
que ce soit shirov les bas reliefs sont
à un demi point derrière kasparov
kasparov joue contre adams qui est à un
point donc les quatre premiers se
rencontrent kasparov joue contre adams
si on fait barrière qui sont un demi
point derrière jouent ensemble donc si
kasparov part d' aventure par exemple
fait partie nulle si l'iran fut marié
flanc portes y terminent à égalité avec
kasparov et donc premier ex-aequo oui ce
qui ne satisfait pas du tout déry
kasparov bien entendu puisque il est
quand même là pour gagner tout seul
voilà peut pas seulement gagner le
tournoi il veut écraser le tournoi voilà
donc dans la dernière ronde il était un
peu dos au mur bon il est un petit peu
dos au mur il a juste un demi point en
avance s'il ne gagne pas il a le risque
que sur un fait bahreïn rejoigne sur le
fil
donc il doit mettre le paquet contre
adamski adams est un petit peu son
client et on va dire je crois que
oui c'est on peut dire que c'est un peu
le client de kasparov dans la mesure où
adams obtint très souvent des positions
prometteuse mais n'arrive jamais à
conclure et en général
à force d'essayer de jouer pour le gain
de forcer devant la résistance de
kasparov qui ne laisse rien rien filer
il finit toujours par c'est un peut
s'envoler et laisser complètement tous
passés et kasparov on gagne c'est à dire
que la dame soit un très très mauvais
score même dans les pétitions supervia
alors jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui je
sais aujourd'hui jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc kasparov joue donc entre adam ci ne
gagne pas il prend le risque de se faire
rattraper par shirov et bas relief qui
jouent ensemble par cher ou barrière
puisque l'un des deux peut marquer le
point et rejoindre kasparov
il ya un autre risque aussi stéphane
c'est quand je vois cette partie il peut
perdre et à ce moment là il ne gagnera
carrément pas le tendre à oui tout à
fait si chaffin à moins que le chiffre
fait part hier fasse match nul à ce
moment là ils seraient quatre premiers
ex-aequo
voilà ce qui serait quand même moins
nous voilà donc dernière ronde neuvième
ronde de ce tournoi kasparov en 2000
points d'avance joue contre adams qui
d'habitude
disons ils sont entre guillemets son
client et shirov et barrier jouent
ensemble
donc pour essayer de rejoindre le king
sur le fil pour gagner à égalité ce
tournoi donc on va analyser tout de
suite cette partie
kasparov contre adams donc qui se joue
la dernière ronde du tournoi
kasparov donc aller blanc doit
l'emporter pour être sûrs de terminer
premiers et il a le risque de se faire
rejoindre donc par shirov et barrières
voilà donc si on peut voir la partie
alors on va tout de suite
commencer cette partie je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez suivre cette partie avec
nous de différentes façons vous avez un
applet java
si vous regardez la partie avec nous sur
l'icône jouer en cliquant dessus vous
avez un applet java dont qui reprend la
partie dont vous pouvez suivre vous même
à votre rythme la partie donc en même
temps que nous-mêmes voir si vous êtes
curieux voire la fin de cette partie
pour savoir ce qui s'est passé vous avez
là aussi la possibilité de télécharger
un fichier pgn format standard et dans
la partie émission de diagonale vous
allez la possibilité de télécharger un
logiciel ou une board pour pc ou mac
pièces pour mac pour regarder ce fichier
pgn qui se lit grâce à ce logiciel donc
deux façon pour vous de suivre la partie
avec nous soit grâce à notre app est
j'avais intégré à l'émission soit en
téléchargeant ce fichier avec
l'installation préalable du logiciel
spécifique
voilà alors tout de suite eloi voyant
comment se déroule cette partie kasparov
contre adams oui donc pour commencer on
peut rappeler kasparov et peuvent être
polyvalent il peut jouer toutes les
ouvertures et donc ici choisi une
ouverture spéciale contre adams c'est en
fonction du style de joueur il décide de
jouer aux quatre éléments structurants
de roi sur quoi dames jouent
systématiquement l'espagnol joue
toujours au 5 avec donc le fameux gang
îles marshall dont on a beaucoup parlé
ou une possibilité mais je crois que
c'est justement le joue souvent à dam se
joue systématique ces sons c'est ça
toute seule ouverture favorite ouverture
fétiche oui tout à fait donc la question
que doit se poser voilà donc la parole
joue le coup logique de lui le mans qui
jouait quasiment à 100% d'ailleurs dans
le haut niveau un coup logique à la fois
de développement cavaliers le cabinet f3
et attaque le pion à eux cinq a tout
simplement
camélia c6 donc jusque là on en est au
2e coude possibilité de jouer l'espagnol
pour kasparov en jouant donc ce coup
fourré fin en b 5
voilà donc ça serait ça serait rentré
dans le jeu d'adams ça serait rentré sur
la préparation physique d'adams puisque
sur cette espagnole à moins que kasparov
des vis de la grande variante adam
placerait le fameux gang dit marshall
qu'on a déjà analysé avait d'ailleurs la
partie historique capablanca marshall
que je vous invite à revoir dans une de
nos émissions précédentes jouer en 1918
et qui était la révélation dans le monde
de ce fameux de cette fameuse ouverture
joué par le génial américain marshall
contre le champion du monde cubain
capablanca en 1918 à new york
oui donc rappel sur les antécédents
kasparov dans cette ouverture maintenant
il ne joue plus trop fou des 5 puisqu'il
a justement peur du gambit marshall
apparemment il a évité tous les joueurs
de combines marchal il ne les provoque
pas sur cette ouverture
on peut penser qu'il a rien trouvé ou
encore ce qu'ils pensaient qu'il a une
préparation fracassante qui réservent
pour une partie très importante voilà
c'est ce que je fais c'est plutôt mon
avis à mon avis le joue pas c'est pas
tellement qu'il en a peur il a peur de
rien comme le disait son manager blanc
shapira d'un tonneau shapira qu'on avait
déjà invité sur cette émission kasparov
n'a pas peur mais il peut être
effectivement s'il a une préparation
contre selon billy préfère cela réservé
pour par exemple championnat du monde
officiel qui pourrait avoir eu bientôt
donc il préfère ressortir pardon dans
d'autres armes contre contre adams et
donc qui joue au troisième coup le coût
des deux des quatre donc la partie
écossaise on avait déjà vu cette
ouverture dans une partie commenté
précédemment qui était donc morose et
beach toujours entre signaux du temps
notamment clown donc kasparov s'est fait
une spécialité un peu avec cette
ouverture puisqu'elle avait réussi à
surprendre karpov lui même aux
championnats du monde de lyon voilà
c'est la première fois que cette
ouverture était jouée dans un match de
championnat
voilà c'est donc c'était une surprise
c'est une ouverture entre guillemets un
petit peu obsolètes ou qui était
considéré comme tel jusqu'à que kasparov
l'arrêt en plus en championnat du monde
ouverture écossaise jouer au siècle
dernier surtout dans les tournois
internationaux mais qui n'avait jamais
été jouée avant kasparov en championnat
du monde officiel oui tout à fait alors
de remarques
la première c'est que c'est un cookie
et vraiment sur les bases anciennes
c'est à dire que très vite on prononce
on prend le centre ont mêlé d'options au
centre ici au 4 et des quatre et on voit
que toutes les pièces sont outil de prêt
à sortir aussi bien le fou c'est un peu
fou en f1 donc ça développe rapidement
les pièces et alors l'autre remarque sur
cette ouverture c'est l'écossaise entre
les mains kasparov c'est une arme
redoutable
il a battu karpov il a battu à nantes il
a battu nicoli tch il me semble qu'il a
battu également sokolov
donc ça fait quatre grands maîtres qui
l'a vraiment massacrés dans l'ouverture
il ya très peu de nul c'est à dire
qu'ils ne jouent pas souvent mais quand
il le joue c'est bien qu'elle se lancer
pour marquer le point
oui donc c'est ça c'est ça entre
guillemets sa variante magique
son arme secrète voilà un arme secrète
c'est comme kasparov 12,7 cette variante
classe c'est vraiment parce qu'il veut
marquer le point
donc là on va passer rapidement sur les
prochains coups puisque si on les a déjà
vus on les a déjà commenté dans la
partie de bronze et beach nos pions
prend des quatre cavaliers prend des
quatre cavaliers f6 fidèle aux principes
d'ouverture adam sorcier cavaliers
rapidement cavaliers français 6 alors ce
coup voilà donc la l'oréal idée l'idée
pour les alors l'idée pour les blancs
vivant sans prendre ce cavalier les
noirs vont être obligés de reprendre
d'un pion essaie donc de casser la
structure
des pions adverse oui oui c'est l'idée
principale d'autant plus que en fait on
est obligé de reprendre avec le pion b
dans cette position puisque si on prend
du plomb eux
en plus de la mauvaise structure on
aurait tous les désavantages puisqu'il
viendrait jouer d'amsterdam roi près et
en force et on aurait eu une très belle
position avec le roi noir des rockets
qui ne sait plus trop où aller en fait
bon se voile alors le roi noir et rory
l'impossibilité de faire l'europe
puisqu'il a bougé donc on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas faire l'europe qu'une fois
que le roi a bougé et les noirs se
retrouver se retrouverait avec que des
désavantages où aucun aucun avantage
pour eux aucun n'est toute la structure
blanche de la structure des pions
blanche serait parfaite
pas de pas de pas de faiblesse alors que
les puits en noir aurait des problèmes
de mobilité puisqu'il se gênent en étant
doublés ils se gênent l'un et l'autre
pour pouvoir avancer et créer des
crédits
des menaces donc logiquement il reprend
donc au cinquième coup avec dépensé 6 ce
qui a un principe simple dans les
ouvertures que tout le monde peut
appliquer c'est avec les pions quand une
reprise se présente il faut toujours
reprendre en allant vers le centre voilà
cette option b ici en reprenant sous
cette case se rapproche du centre et
tout de suite il a une action sur la
case des scènes qui contrôle cette case
très bien l'on peut noter que c'est un
petit désavantage c'est vrai mais de
notre côté maintenant les noirs encore
même aussi enfin il ya des avantages et
des inconvénients puis un doublé ont
plutôt des désavantages en général mais
ici une petite peut-être majorité
centrale qui va permettre au noir de
d'attaqué au sein de très vite
soutenu par par ce fameux petit pion c6
oui on part quand sept pions c7 qui lui
est pénalisé oui on se demande souvent
pourquoi les pions doublé sont mauvais
et la réponse nous vient de ninkovic qui
a dit que les pions doublé sont très
forts sauf quand il essaie d'avancer
c'est à dire qu'en fait les viandes ou
blessés c'est très solide en défense
puisque ça contrôle beaucoup de cases
disons qu'ils se qui se touche en fait
des casques anti gay vous voyez toutes
ces cases la saa contrôle donc c'est
assez compact ses compacts wallace est
très compact par contre dès qu'on essaie
d'avancer et bella ça ça s'en mêle
puisque ça n'a aucune force n'a aucun
impact puisque les pions ne contrôle pas
les cases qui sont juste devant veut
donc ils ont du mal à avancer
voilà la police et donc ses deux pions
c'est le pion csn ne peut pas tout
simplement pas bougé de toute façon donc
et il ya une seule mobilité sur cette
colonne ici contre les blancs ici ils
ont deux mobilité ils ont le pion b et
le pion c'est qu'ils sont mobiles un
avantage de mobilité classique pour les
pieds doublé voilà voilà donc on
continue
6e coup eu cinq attaquants le cavadee m6
alors là un petit truc on joue d'abord
danos est donc qui cloue l'option vous
voyez le pion e5 ne peut pas prendre le
cas il ya six disques à ce moment là le
roi blanc sera en prise à coup numéro 6
des noirs pour que vous suiviez la
partie avec votre logiciel ou l'applet
donc six dames 7 et le pion blanc ici il
ne peut pas bouger à cause donc de
clouage quand tu
il voit le roi blanc sort est un échec
voilà donc kasparov chou dames 2 tout ça
très bien connu le cavalier cette fois
ci j'ai vraiment attaqué mal an les
avantages d'un mode de vie dans ça
protège le pion et en même temps sa
menace de prendre puisque maintenant il
n'y a plus le clouage la dame ne ferait
plus de chèque au roi donc une urgence
coup en fait sa menace de prendre le
cavalier oui donc on s'en va cavaliers
des cinq très logique 8e coûte kasparov
c4 donc encore une fois logique on l'a
le cabinet viennent sur une case
centrale où il est plus actif
évidemment que sur une case il aurait
été obligé de revenir en à sa case
principal il n'y a pas d'autres coûts et
donc ici au centre il est bien placé
mais il est saoul à sous le feu
justement des pions mobile des blancs
oui oui oui exactement
donc d'ailleurs kasparov ne se prive pas
d'attaquer cette pièce dangereuse alors
là il ya deux embranchements possibles
fois ci ce qui avait donc le fou s'est
vite pour revenir en a6 effectuons un
nouveau clouage sur la dame blanche
voilà ou alors partir avec le cavalier
donc le coût qui a été choisi par adams
huit cavaliers b6 ses docs ou à peu près
de valeur équivalente
donc si on avait joué une fois ci ce
voile allait revenir dans la dombes
l'idéal fois ci c'est qu'on ne développe
une pièce sexy le pion blanc prend
évidemment le fou pouvait reprendre ici
la dame donc mais là c'est bien le choix
en fait c'est un choix d'ouverture
le cavalier abc s'est bien défendu et ne
risque pas grand chose et alors là
kasparov c'est là qu'il avait préparé la
surprise je pense pour michael adams
puisque dans toutes ses parties
précédentes il avait joué cavalier b1 en
d2 notamment contre karpov ou match au
championnat du monde
il avait joué son coup cavale et b1 en
d2 qui défendent si on s'écarte en fait
qui surprotègent un peu ce point là et
qui en plus donc sans une pièce est ici
kasparov changer joue un coup un peu un
peu moins connu un peu moins reconnus
par la théorie il joue cavalier c3 alors
le le dessin
quelle peut être avantageux
l'inconvénient secoue le bon d'abord
c'est un coût de développement c'est en
clair ça c'est en avant par contre par
rapport en développement sur cette case
ici c'est le pion c4 est moins bien
protégés oui tout à fait mais alors par
contre il protège il contrôle des cases
plus avant dans le camp noir
oui alors c'est ça c'est un peu
discutable dans la mesure où où les
cases que tu indiqué donc b5 et des cinq
sont quand même bien contrôlé par le
pion c6 donc je pense que l' avantage
principal du développement de kbc 3
comparé aux cavaliers des deux c'est que
ça laisse libre champ aux phocéens
alors il vaut mieux sortir maintenant à
peu près quand il voudra donc ça c'est
ça c'est l'idée en fait ils cherchent un
développement plus rapide de ses forces
une mobilisation plus rapide et en
compensation il a fait bien peu sont
fiancés 4 adams donc d'adams un profil
tout 2006 alors oui effectivement alors
ce coup donc ce 9 pour les noirs le 9
pour les noirs dame a eu 6 a pour
avantage un peu la même chose sur le
cavalier si libéré fou l'a enjoint ce
couvent les noirs font une pression sur
le pion c4i six cavaliers et dames bon
c'est pour l'instant protégé par les
blancs par la dame et le fou met une
petite pression qui commence à s'exercer
et le fou noir surtout ici en fuite va
pouvoir sortir permettant noire de m
leroy à l'abri par le petit robert le
petit rock tout à fait donc adams en
fait joue assez positionnelle cette
variante c'est à dire qu'ils essaient de
sortir ces pièces ce qui est assez ce
qui en fait un des principes un grand
principe de l'ouverture il veut sortir
toutes les pièces le plus vite possible
hélas kasparov donc c'est un peu
c'est un peu pareil c'est à dire que là
il met sa dame en vaux cap donc ils
centralisent saddam continuer à protéger
à la fois son pion un an ces quatre et
e55 voilà la dame continue à protéger
les deux points et il libère et libère
donc le faut pour sortir très vite alors
ce qu'on peut dire donc ça fait
longtemps qu'on en a pas parlé dans
l'émission on en parle beaucoup au début
c'était pour les va évaluer une position
d'un point de vue statique ou dynamique
très important donc sur le long terme
sur le court terme donc là ce qu'on voit
c'est que si les joueurs se contentent
chacun de leur côté de sortir leurs
pièces les petits ont doublé vont finir
par être faible et donc ça serait
al'avantage de kasparov
c'est à dire que si mettons adams jouer
un coup comme fou aux 7
kasparov mais t'en fous et 2 passes et
des coûts de développement mais je
dirais c'est tranquille ce n'est pas des
bons pour cdc tranquille c'est le voilà
ces découpes des coûts très simple
après petit rock et petit rock les
blancs réel avantage puisque ce cavalli
b6 resterait hors jeu éventuellement
après un simple coup comme b2 b3 voilà
il aurait très peu de cases à sa
disposition pour pour nous pour rentrer
en jeu via le centre enfin il n'a sauvé
un peu à l'est les un peu hors jeu et
les pions doublé serait toujours ne
pourrai toujours pas bougé sera donc
faibles donc ici adams va chercher des
chances qu'on appelle dynamique
ces terres qui va essayer de jouer
rapidement il essaie de faire valoir
rapidement ses chances le plus vite
possible
donc tout de suite il joue faux b4 voilà
le fou on en est au 10e coupe au 10e
coup pour les noirs un coup logique de
développement à la fois on sort le fou
sur la case b4 ici créant une pression
sur le cavalier lecavalier d'ailleurs ne
peut pas bouger puisque le roi blanc
derrière serait derrière donc le
cavalier et bien clouer et les noirs
prépare le tout simplement le petit rock
peut-être une menace aussi pour les
noirs c'est de prendre ce cavalier et
eux mêmes créé des pions doublé oui dans
le camp des blancs oui tout à fait alors
cette menace peut être appuyé par une
variante en plus c'est à dire qu'après
fou prend ses 3 si on prend ces trois on
peut jouer fous ces huit ans on a six
qui attaquent le pion c4 et ce point on
ne peut plus être défendu que et trois
fois il sera attaqué trois fois défendu
seulement deux fois et le pion n'étant
plus en b2 mais en c3 ne pourra plus
venir en b3 pour justement soutenir son
collègue donc des avantages des pions
doublé peut-être donc des avantages des
peines doublées peut-être un d un des
désavantages des faux nobles
donc kasparov ne permet pas ça c'était
pas c'était pas considéré pour lui il
vous faut c'est en d2 défendant son
caddie avec le fouet donc gardant cette
option toujours de b2 b3 qui est très
important puisque après ce coup x 6
cette structure là va enfermer
complètement les deux pièces de michael
adams le fonds à six et le cavaly b6
seront emmuré par cette structure là
donc très logique
une construction très logique de
kasparov michael adams chaud à 6 alors
pourquoi l'un fut effectivement
incidents déjà il peut pas tellement
aller vers le centre puisque ses pions
ici sont un petit peu bon mais son
doublé déjà sombre sont faibles et s'il
arrivait trop vite vers le centre mais
kasparov pourrait faire des prises
multiples probablement à son avantage
est par contre une autre possibilité
pour l'un soit peut-être de jouer le fou
en baisse est peut-être oui ça aurait pu
être une possibilité d'ailleurs c'en est
une mais alors donc ça c'est pas bon sur
ce qu'on avait dit le concept de
statisme dynamisme c'est un coup trop
lent fou 17
adam soit chercher ses chances tout de
suite après fo bessette ça va laisser
libre champ à kasparov pour sortir ces
pièces il va pouvoir jouer fou détroit
tranquillement suite petit rock et une
fois son développement achevé la
position blanche sera à l avantage de
kasparov donc adams ne veut pas
permettre ça il a prévu une suite fort
c'est ici et donc il va il va saisir sa
chance tout de suite avant kasparov est
terminée
oui avant que kaspar se mobiliser et
prennent avantage de la faiblesse des
pierres noires
oui donc ce qu'on peut dire surtout
bessette c'est que ce n'est pas une
faute disons ce n'est pas une faute
tactique c'est une faute stratégique
positionne elle parce que de la suivre
voilà la menace d' adam saint jouin ce
coup c'est tout simplement mais par
exemple vous prend à ses 4 et après faut
prendre ces quatre des blindes d'un
prince et 4 les blancs les noirs ont
gagné tout simplement un pion un pion
donc kasparov joue b3 voilà donc la
premier premières positions critiques
mais que la dame sa sortie toutes ces
pièces avec petit rock qui va rien avait
il va ça va rien lui apporter du tout
s'ils jouent petit rock en plus qu'un
sport va gagner du temps je m'en fous
des trois menaces en maths avec la dame
ah oui d'emprunt d'un point en tête
donc ça obligerait et noir à jouer
encore un coup de qui ne sert à rien et
kasparov finirait sa mobilisation avec
optimum par petit rock et les noirs
n'aurait n'aurait pas réussi à dix on a
déstabilisé les blancs et se
retrouverait toujours avec cette les dom
vayssette cette structure de pions mal
placé et ces deux pièces emmuré par
cette espèce de mur a ici et qui les
empêche de bouger
le cahier ne peut pas venir le d5 par
exemple puisque le pion peut prendre le
pion évidemment ici est imprenable à
cause du cube et 3 donc ces deux pièces
ne joue pas vraiment et c'est un c'est
un des avantages certains
oui oui tout à fait donc adams joue faux
procès 3 donc ça c'est une séquence
c'est un mauvais coup positionnelle
puisque ça c'est de la paire de fou mais
ça va être suivie par la paire de
pousser avec les noirs les blancs pardon
se retrouvent après la reprise ici en c3
d'ailleurs kasparov évidemment reprend
le fou c'est un échange
les blancs se retrouve avec le fou c3 et
le fouet fin donc de fou contre deux
pièces mineurs qui en plus pour
l'instant sont très mal placés
oui faut absolument qu adam ce matin
justifie justifie sa séquence de coûts
pour démontrer que mais il peut arriver
à égaliser la position et donc ils
jouent des 5 alors on comprend
maintenant pourquoi il a pris ce
qu'avait laissé 3 avant de jouer des 5
c'est parce que ce cavalier défendez la
dame blanche
maintenant elle n'est plus défendu ci a
donc créé un clouage sur ce plan là
l'option ne peut plus prendre en passant
puisque sinon il rêve d'un grand talent
on peut signaler peut-être un petit
point effectivement après ce coup dans
le coup de 13 des noirs 17 en d5 permet
aux blancs
s'ils le souhaitent de faire la prise en
passant donc on rappelle juste
rapidement les principes puisque c'est
pas un coup très très usuels mais qui
existent aux échecs
le pin blanc ici aux cinq as le droit de
considérer juste le coup d'après que le
pion noir est encore sur la case des 6
et donc de pouvoir le prendre en jouant
sur la case des six est le pur non
harrison 5 disparaîtrait et donc ça
c'était c'est la possibilité qu'ont les
blancs évidemment si maintenant les
blancs le fonds qui ont 5 38 ans des six
le pion des cinq disparaît mais les
noirs prendrait la dame blanche qui
n'est pas défendu
puisque la dame noire mais n'en serait
pour elles à prendre donc c'est l'idée
de supprimer d'abord le cavalier ici en
c3 et adams qui était donc de supprimer
cette défense dame blanche ne permettant
pas aux blancs de près
ici en passant sous forme de coups et
oui et donc maintenant que la prise en
passant n'est plus possible kasparov a
un problème puisque vous voyez saddam
est attaqué et le pion c4 aussi en fait
voilà donc il imagine aussi bouge la
dame par exemple donc mettons enfin il a
bougé la dame donc on y viendra après si
il a joué des matches 4 dans la partie
oui qui sacrifient un pion maintenant
s'il avait repris la skin havel avait le
mérite de ne pas perdre d'options adams
aurait repris encore une fois attaquons
la dame et sur un coude dames le ku'damm
qui va suivre de garry kasparov il
rejouait fou quand fu est fin voyez oui
hélas absent soit après roy prend fou
soit après tout reprend foule et blanc
auraient été privés du petit rock et
donc ce roi se serait retrouvé un peu
dans l'est dans les courants d'air et au
passage les filles ont doublé aurait
disparu oui voilà et le mauvais fond
aurait disparu aussi oui c'est à dire
que les noirs en reprenant donc
j'imagine qu'ils on prend qui en prend
attaque à la dame est évidemment les
deux pions noirs c7 et des 5 du cours
retrouver leur mobilité totale et le
pion c5 peut bouger le pion des singles
aussi peu bougé donc ça aurait été un
ave un échec pour les blancs un échec
pour les blancs enfin plutôt un succès
de la stratégie
de beats krieg qu'on peut on peut
l'appeler comme ça de michael adams donc
ici kasparov sacrifie lappion et joue au
14e coupe d'un match 4 donc un coût
assez logique finalement il pour le prix
d'un pion il va il va laisser les pions
doublé ce qui est quand même assez
important aussi
donc les noirs prennent sur la
logiquement maintenant s'il est blanc
reprennent les noirs pour peuvent faire
d ici des échanges sur la casse ces
cartes et avoir gagné un pion tout
simplement oui oui même si les deux
pions qui leur restent ici sont quand
même faible
oui cent des faiblesses possible mais
c'est quand même bien en plus donc c'est
pas forcément il faut que kasparov
trouve quelque chose de toute façon
kasparov n'est absolument pas pressé de
prendre là dans la mesure où ce options
actuellement est cloué c'est à dire
qu'il peut pas prendre là car il
suivrait fouet f136 se fout n'étant pas
défendu ce serait la perte sèche d'une
pièce pour pour les noirs voilà donc là
le kasparov logiquement pas n'ayant rien
de mieux à faire va continuer son
développement et j'en doute qu'on voit
là tout simplement celles qui fondent un
coup très simple mais effectivement les
noirs ne peuvent pas prendre tout de
suite en tout cas le pion b3 à cause de
tout simplement la perte du x 6 ce pion
lui-même et est doublé on peut noter que
mcadams à itunes plus mais ce sont des
pions triplé dit oui dans des tons
mobilité vendant minimale donc c'est pas
vraiment gênant pour kasparov en fait en
échange du pion il mobilise un petit peu
les fortement il arrive allez allez
allez
scotché sur place oui c'est celle en
fait au niveau de la structure de pions
le sacrifice d'un pion est pleinement
justifiée puisque vous voyez que la ses
pions ne ressemble à rien c6 c7 est à
sept îles ont aucune action group
c'est vraiment une succession de trois
pions indépendant qui ne soutiennent pas
des uns les autres
olympisme pas vraiment menaçants alors
oui ici je voulais donc y revenir à
cette position après 15 faut deux
puisque adams a quand même encore la
possibilité de jouer petit rock achevant
son développement oui mais il cherche
encore
ils cherchent plus c'est à dire qu'il se
dit bon voilà
kasparov n'a pas encore roque et son fou
et emprises solution également peut être
en prise n'est protégé que par le fou le
fouet de on sait pas trop le roi est au
centre
je vais essayer de saisir ma chance
maintenant c'est à dire il veut il veut
pas laisser un temps de 1 temps de repos
à kasparov avec petit rock
il décide encore d'envoyer ses forces à
l'attak
il a bon il a calculé assez loin les
calculs une séquence qu'on appelle de
simplification donc on va la voir tout
de suite
joe 15e coup cavaliers dessin
al'avantage aussi ce que lecavalier est
centralisé maintenant maintenant donc il
a une action est tout de suite
d'ailleurs ils menacent de prendre le
fou en c3 donc il déjà beaucoup plus
actif que sur la case de siphon et tout
est fait alors moi est ce qu'on peut
dire qu'effectivement c'est que dès
qu'il a pu partir de cette case
d'éclosion c4 n'est plus là il est
revenu vers le centre ce qui est tout à
fait tout à fait logique
kasparov va en d4 donc petite variante
très simple s'il était revenu en b2 ça
aurait permis à michael adams de jouer
ces quatre c3 c'est à dire sans
s'occuper du cloud âge et surtout prend
fou à 6 le pion vient de répondre ce fou
en b2 donc on aurait réussi à éliminer
ce note dernière mauvaise pièce à
prendre se fout là avec un tube très
dangereux et en plus le pierrot 5 sera
en prise avec et chaque attaquant la
tour donc ici qu'à sport tu ne peux pas
les en b2 il est obligé d'aller en d4
pour garder la défense options 2,5 et la
adams continue ce le harcèlement de ce
fou avec 16e coup ces cinq voiliers ce
coup de pied un peu un pion kamikazes
c'est à dire qu'ici le faut bien le
prendre adams trouvera du contre jeu va
se venger en fait sur le pion de 5 mais
de toute façon il n'y a pas trop de
choix pour kasparov
donc il prend il est obligé de prendre
ce plan 17e coup qui récupère déjà
champion l'option qu'il avait données
michael adams laurent rapidement ça ne
leur ont pas puisque il va normalement
prendre le pion au 5 février
à oui alors voila voila anicroche départ
dense et c'est là que ça commence à
chauffer oui donc sur dame prend pions
ici je pense que kasparov avait prévu de
le retour du fou simplement fous ces
cinq ans des quatre attaquants la dame
soutenu par l'adam cirque la dame ne
peut pas prendre puisque le fou des cats
et défendu la dame doit s'en aller et
après on joue petit rock par exemple la
dame et attention parce que
effectivement imaginons dimpre ambiant
pour les poulets noir donc le four
reviendrait sur la case de d4 et le
peut-être le pion g7 aussi pourrait être
en prise oui
avec faut prendre g7 qui pourrait être
très désagréable oui et il ya également
un autre coup a mentionné donc c'est au
lieu de vous décapent sûr d'un point que
ça serai petit rock tout de suite
stéphane a brillé aussi qu'à l'air
puisque ah oui oui qui a l'air très
dangereux puisque oui effectivement ça
mobilise rapidement les forces et se
fout ne peut pas être pris voyez la dame
en 5 si elle venait prendre le fou on
suivrait pas retour f1 avec clouage de
la dame voilà jeu mortel
la dame ne pourrait pas bougé ici en
veut deux puisque maintenant que le pion
à cinq a disparu le bon la tour est ici
en un c'est la dame rouge évidemment le
roi sera un échec et on peut noter aussi
que sur petit rock
imaginons d'emprunt pions petit rock bon
avantage aussi c'est que ça défend la
tour qui était attaquée puisque la tour
maintenant effet un protège on peut
noter aussi que le roi noir ne peut pas
bouger puisque le fou contrôler la case
et fuite
la dame en h4 contrôler la case des huit
donc les blancs avec un coup simple
finissent leur développement complet le
roi est à l'abri les deux tours sont
prêtes à rentrer en jeu et les noirs
sont à une possibilité immédiate de m
leroy eux mêmes à l'abri donc ce sont
sujets à une attaque qui peut s'avérer
très violente
oui on était
kasparov pour gagner la partie très très
rapidement donc michael adams va faire
une petite un coup intermédiaire il va
jouer son cavalier des cinq ans et 3
vous voyez ici donc ça empêche kasparov
de roquet puisque maintenant sur petit
rock donc le cavalier viendrait prendre
le fou avec l'échec
oui donc très mauvaises langues pour
kasparov en même temps sa menace donc de
jouer cavalier profond et 2 forçant à
1.122 donc déjà dayraut cache des rois
blanc et on peut suivre par dame prend
2,5 échec suite d'un prof ou c5
oui vous aussi non le fou pour y revenir
mais en pleurer on pourrait aussi
prendre le plan b 3 avec un échec du fou
à 6 chaque année il se réveille au ray
avec comme plan b 3 ha ben touchable il
faut parer les chèques et après ce pire
on ne peut devenir très très dangereux
pour les noirs donc là
kasparov est obligé de bouger son fouet
2 donc il va en profiter au passage
donc on en n 10 et un coût des noirs
cavaliers c3t ce paraphe récupère un
pion avec 18 france et 4
donc là la séquence est quasiment forcé
au nom d'ailleurs je dis une bêtise
puisque les noirs ont le choix entre
jouer d'un projet cinq échecs ou fou
kung fu d'abord alors
l'inconvénient de fou qu'on fout d'abord
c'est que ça permettrait à la dame de
kasparov de revenir sur cette carte c4
et sa adams veut pas puisque sa garderie
un peu la structure de kasparov intact
avec les pions à 2 et b3 toujours un mec
peut-être pour échanger les dames mais
on peut imaginer donc pour valence donc
enfin il ya plusieurs possibilités
vivant il peut prendre le pion avec
échec - il met les castors se défendre
est tout simplement avec le fou 1 2 3 et
après pourrait faire le petit rock sans
difficulté et surtout prend fout pas tu
proposes donc dame prend fou attaque un
cavalier et aussi accessoirement
éventuellement la dame macadam pourrait
essayer de simplifier la position en
prenant la dame
oui alors le problème de cette variante
c'est qu'il resterait avec un taux moins
puisque il a près d'un grand dam piotr
en dame
il pourrait plus prendre le cuir aux 5
et oui il aurait donc ça fera une finale
avec un tour - ce qui n'est pas ce qui
n'est pas le but est donc ça aurait
permis à la dame de revenir en jeu alors
que michael adams a trouvé beaucoup plus
fort donc c'est à mon avis avait ainsi
pu anticiper très longtemps à l'avancé
par michael adams il joue dame champions
échec d'accord kasparov doit reculer
avec le fou oui parce que sinon le fouet
perdu france et 5 donc il revient
défendre tout simplement tranquillement
voilà maintenant cavalier e 4 alors la
très jolie qui avait déjà quatre
attaques la torah et intercepte
la dame ah oui oui d'accord bien dire
cet adam donc maintenant kasparov doit
défendre sa tour un don qui n'en
profitent pour roque et en même temps
donc il attire protéger mais du coup la
dame ne protège plus évidemment le fond
ces quatre îles tonga au cou numéro 21
connue et robin par pardon pour les
noirs mac à la danse peut prendre le fou
c4 obligeant kasparov à détruire sa
propre structure de pions en reprenant
du pion dit on mais voilà hélas les la
structure des pions noire et blanche est
complètement égaliser et a pris le coup
suivant de michael adams voilà qui le
petit rock au 21e coup il semblerait que
ce soit une égalité alors quasi parfaite
je dirais sauf que mais les blancs ont
quand même un fou contre 2me cavaliers
ce qui est toujours un petit avantage
oui c'est un avantage notamment de
répression ouverte donc ça très
important
pourquoi pour une raison géométriques en
fait le fou peut passer d'un bout à
l'autre de l'échiquier en un seul coup
voilà alors que le cavalier est quand
même ne se déplace que de deux cases à
la fois donc le kali mais beaucoup plus
de temps pour passer d'une zone de
l'échiquier à une autre alors que le fou
passe instantanément d'une zone à
l'autre
imaginons une finale par exemple roi est
roi et puis des pions sur les deux ailes
mais le fou pourrait contrôler à la fois
en défense ses pions et aider à la
promotion de ces autres pions pour les
verts la dame alors que lecavalier ne
pourrait agir que sur une seule voie est
donc un avantage certain en finale pour
le full qu'un quel fou oui alors ce
qu'on peut mettre aussi comme avantage
pour le cavalier quand même c'est que
lecavalier est beaucoup plus efficace
sur zone
c'est à dire que sur la quantité sur une
petite zone de l'échiquier et contrôler
les cases blanches et les 4 noir
c'est-à-dire deux fois plus de cas ce
que le fou oui voilà donc sa simple
rappel géométriques donc là kasparov
donc cette position après le 21e coude
et noir petit rock
il doit il doit chercher des chances bon
c'est quand même minime comme avantage
un fou contre un cavalier mais
lecavalier n'a pas de
on n'a pas de bonnes cases sur
l'échiquier oui qu'il peut pas être
soutenus par un pion il peut pas il peut
pas rester là donc kasparov va
maintenant chercher des chances violente
imaginons par exemple mclane sport des
points si lecavalier par exemple revient
sur la case f6 un exemple le fonds
pourrait venir un des quatre attaquants
la dame et après fou prend un f6 par
exemple plus si la dame reprend les
blancs pourrait reprendre un cas sans
complètement la structure des pions
noirs de ce côté-là et un avantage on
avantage assez nette en finale le tenant
en finale de tournois tout à fait saine
des ventes mais kasparov cherche mieux
que ça donc ils commencent par le tour
et fera un petit coup qui a l'air de
rien alors à partir de ce moment là
c'est fantastique comme encas sport ne
va plus le laisser souffler c'est à dire
que la dame ce ne pourra pas reprendre
son souffle avec son cavalier qui va et
qui va errer un peu partout sur les
chiffres kasparov a sûrement déjà des
menaces
oui donc e-menaces menace assez simple
on peut dire ce serait fou points 7
voilà voilà par exemple vous prend à ces
deux cas les reins oui un revers
surprenant et les noirs pourraient
reprendre le fou et après on fait le
cavalier se réattaquer maintenant par la
tour et par la dame dont kaspar pour
reprendre la dame oui et après d'âpres
en dames tout reprend dames les blancs
se retrouverait avec le pion à 2 en plus
besoin d'eau en plus donc petit avantage
mais donc petite menace tout de suite de
kasparov
oui oui donc mais que la dame serait
logique un réplica touré fin par touré
fut vite
donc tout ça très normal et la f3 ça y
est kasparov pose la question d'en
croquer vallier le cahier doit choisir
sa case de repli plaie en f 6 ou en d6
est donc un choix qui attention parce
que donc une fois que si le fou joue
après derrière on peut remarquer que la
dame serait emprise de la tour oui c'est
là l'idée de kasparov évidemment c'est
de créer des menaces sur cet empilement
de pièces ici sur la colonne qui sont
finalement pas très bien placé mais
surtout la dame en fait puisque la tour
c'est pas très grave
et donc il vend des six alors l'autre
alternative donc du 23e coup des noirs
c'était de venir en f 6 avec lecavalier
mais là c'était réfuté simplement par la
petite combinaison qu'on ait mentionné
fou prend à cet attaquant la dame
la dame doit bouger et le four partira
dès le coup d'après en f2 sur une case
totalement sûr
et au passage une rafle mais les blancs
auraient gagné un pion alors voyons ce
que c'est
donc il va en d6 maintenant sur fond à 7
michael adams j'aurais dame c3 avec
vengeance sur l'option ses 4o coups à
venir voilà c'est à dire que
même ne faudrait pas attention à aux
menaces si j'aurai tout simplement sur
la case ses trois attaquants avec le
cavalier la dame le pion c4 et le fou à
cette continuerait d'être attaqué
également beaucoup trop de menaces donc
c'est la différence entre la caisse des
6 et 6 pour le cavalier c'est que depuis
des six il attaque le pion c4 voilà donc
là hélas kasparov ne l'est toujours pas
soufflé michael adams
voilà c'est à dire qu'à chaque coup il
force quasiment les noirs à trouver
quelque chose c'est des menaces et ça un
petit peu c'est ça il fait des menaces
et donc ça oblige les noirs à jouer des
coups quasi-forcée la méthode un jouet
novare effectivement ce coup 24e coup le
fou vient en f2 libère l'action de la
tour et tout de suite
la dame noire mais doivent se dire mais
où je vais donc la can n'a pas le point
de se dire bon j'ai le choix de
plusieurs coups non non il n'y avait pas
trop pas trop de choix il faut qu'ils
jouent saddam c'est oui en fait non il a
le choix de plusieurs coups toujours
mais il n'a pas le choix de plomb il
peut pas il ne peut pas engager des des
initiatives ne peut pas prendre
d'initiatives il est obligé de se
défendre
donc c'est assez désagréable pour
michael adams il va sur cette case f5
une case comme une autre il y avait
beaucoup de possibilités un club ce coup
là voici maintenant saddam est un peu
plus d'insécurité et la kasparov
continue le harcèlement 25e coup c'est 5
voilà encore une fois un colloque qui
avait pas trop de choix est il obligé de
jouer le cavalier et tôt ou tard il peut
éventuellement faire un échange de tour
préalable
mais en attendant ce cavalier doit
bouger oui alors par exemple donc là
mais que la dame sion b5 donc au 25e
coup sûr votre applet java après
vingt-cinq c5
il y avait un petit choix éventuellement
et pouvez aller ici en bessette
mais là je pense que kasparov aurait
poursuivi par tour prend tour à tour
prompt et maintenant un coup très long
dames 2 h 4 ans à 4 attaquants et la
tour et le pion à sept et on remarquera
au passage que depuis dix-sept
lecavalier occupe une position quand
même pitoyable puisque mal placé dominé
par ce pion et en même temps kasparov
notre indignation ça serait pas
acceptable
donc ici michael adams est tombé 5 car
ce qui n'est pas très très intéressante
non plus les forces et il faut les
problèmes là c'est qu'il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de cases intéressante pour ceux
pour ce cavalier kasparov continue donc
il continue à harceler adamski 10
rebonds alors
goethe oblige encore à trouver un coût
et le cavalier maintenant b5 est attaqué
la dame donc en revenant sur cette case
ici pose la question encore une fois aux
cavaliers mcadams n'a toujours pas le
temps de souffler il faut qu'il réponde
aux menaces et lecavalier n'est plus de
15 en fait stéphanie si vous voyez les
cases à cet essai 7 sont déjà prises la
casse des six est contrôlé par ses pions
la casse des quatre et deux fois
contrôler ses 3es à trois sont
contrôlées par la dame donc lecavalier
n'a plus de gaz il faut alors on peut
imaginer qu'il pourrait défendre ce
cavalier par le coup c7 c6 par exemple
ouais mais tout petit coup de pions
protégerait le cavalier et ménagerait
peut-être une porte de sortie pour ce
cavalier sur la casse c'est 7 mais
sûrement kasparov aura continué par
harceler encore el khayat rhin avec le
coup à 2 à 4 et sûrement qu'après le
coup cavale et c7 la dame serait venu
par exemple sur la case b cet attaquant
à la fois le cavalier et la casse et 6
et posé d'énormes problèmes au noir
encore une fois oui tout à fait d'autant
plus que le pion à s'être et également
aux prises après un échange de tour
éventuel donc capable et is known as à
ce qu'il faut noter c'est que ça n'a
l'air de rien mais mais il est évident
que la une position qui est déjà un peu
épuré comme ça c'est kasparov arriver à
récupérer un pion il va se créer d'abord
un pion passé puisque s'il récupère soit
le pion à 7 soit le pion c7 le pion
correspondant pour les blancs le pion à
2 ici le pion ces cinq seraient libres
ensuite d'aller à dame
et ça serait une menace très forte pour
les blancs et les noirs n'aurait pas de
possibilité de le même de créer de leur
propre menace ni la position blanche ne
possède pas de faiblesse oui on avait
d'autant plus que le cavalier loin de
l'action toujours un homme aimerait bien
créer des contre menace sur le roi de
kasparov mais c'est pas possible donc
ici la finale avec un peu moins seraient
quasiment désespéré alors je me suis
amusé à regarder les parties de kasparov
récemment et j'ai vu toutes les finales
où il inclut en plus il joue dans
vraiment c'est des mathématiques il joue
parfaitement et gagne pratiquement à
chaque fois ce qui est donc pas très
encourageants d'un bal et d'un michael
adams dans cette position
il faut mais pas laisser de pions donc
on défend avec dom détroit bon pourquoi
pas alors l'avantagent peut-être
ci-dessous coup c'est que ça permet
éventuellement aux cavaliers de venir
sur la casse ces trois mois ici te fais
c'est l'idée la dame donc protège de
cavaliers et protège a cassé 3 qui
permettrait de faire venir le cavalier
en jeu via cette case est proposée par
exemple michel sur la case de et des
petites menaces pour mettre en jeu le
cavalier mais évidemment kasparov a vu
plus loin il joue autour des 1 donc
maintenant c'est plus le cavalier qu'il
harcèle mais la dame
donc c'est entendu l'air un petit peu
dire que maintenant la dame doit partir
mais il doit continuer à défendre le
cavalier donc une seule case pour 27e
coude adams ah non eh bien oui voilà
donc que tiko intermédiaire coûts
intermédiaires évidemment juin ce coup
ci les blancs prennent la dame avait
tout simplement les noirs reprendre et
la dame blanche avec égalité
cette fois de matériel et une meilleure
position pour les noirs oui d'autant
plus que encore une fois le pion serait
venu vers le centre skis et ski sur le
plan positionnelle une bonne chose ça
ouvrirait la colonne de la tour sur le
pion à deux donc c'est inacceptable pour
kasparov donc qui continue la pression
sur le cap à 10 ans le cavalier dr c'est
un jouet sur cette case à 4 car il est
toujours attaquer et la dame de dames
sont toujours attaqués aussi il faut
faire attention
donc petite variante puisque là on voit
que kasparov a perdu une fourchette
quand même il permet cavalli c3
éventuellement attaquant et la dame et
la tour ici par exemple donc si la tour
prenait la dame noire lecavalier
pourrait reprendre à laudun moulin mais
il aurait des classes de sortie après un
bep de ou ans et 3 mois là mais sur quel
essai 3 il ya un petit échec
intermédiaire d'un grand tour et cheikh
sarr christiane adams accrue sur la dame
ou un coup tokuda mais maintenant tout
reprendra mais également avec une tour
de plus avec l'histoire de plus voilà
c'est dire que l'argent car les c3 la
dame noire continue tu commences à être
attaqué la dame est attaqué dans ce cas
là on la sacrifie contre maximum de
matériel et après on récupère la dame
noire et on a gagné une tour en fait
donc on a fait ce qu'on a c'est une
combinaison qu'il faut deux types de
combinaisons classiques aux échecs
on est là on a si on a des pièces
de valeur équivalente attaque et on peut
la pièce qui est attaquée peut se
sacrifier
si un échec surtout c'est souvent même
si un échec
et du coup après la reprise la pièce
équivalente adverse peut te récupérer
avec un matériel oui c'est exactement ça
donc ici adams va donc s'en va sur la
seule case encore disponibles qui défend
des lecavalier donc la case aux deux
voilà et kasparov quand ils continuent
d'harceler la dame
vous voyez ça fait au moins dix coups de
suite que kasparov et des menaces donc
là le coude adams et forcé il faut
revenir
voilà donc kasparov évidemment on ne va
pas se satisfaire de la nulle maintenant
ils auraient pu répéter les coups ouais
autour des 1 1 il pour il pourra vous
faire nul mais il a le risque que scheer
en fait par ailleurs le rejoigne voilà
parce que s'il avait un point d'avancé
entier il pourrait faire nul et gagner
le tournoi tranquillement oui faut
toujours se rappeler sa 1,52 risque ça
me fait donc sans prendre le risque de
perdre et se faire rattraper là mais bon
jeu il a déjà il a vu quelque chose on
va voir ce qui est donc ils jouent tout
reprend tout en échec tout reprend et là
il continue encore
donc là le ku'damm s'est efforcé
maintenant tour d un encore une fois
voilà là c'est plus ou moins la fin
puisque on voit que survivre ici
dames 2 coups qu'on est naturel d'adams
il aurait tout re et cette fois ci c'est
plus pareil puisque la dame voitures
venues en d3 regard or qu'est ce que
fait et voilà il abandonne la madone
analogique sur dame deux tours 20 voilà
le problème c'est qu'on l'a redit voilà
faut faut analyser cette position finale
la sai et adams a fini d'être harcelée
par kasparov 5 rue avec très peu de
moyens kasparov a mis une pression
terrible sur les noirs il n'a pas arrêté
d'harceler les pièces adverse on voit
que la dame noire ici évidemment ne peut
pas prendre la tour puisqu'elle est
protégé par la dame
il faut qu'elle continue à protéger ce
cavalier elle est attaquée par la tour
alors la dame c4 évidemment n'est pas
possible à cause de la dame blanche
y'a pas de tellement de notre cas il y
aurait que la case eux deux mais dans ce
cas là le tour eu un protégé de la tour
étant protégé par le fou obligerait la
dame encore une fois à bouger et après
il y aurait tout reprend tour au fond
avec échec et mat
donc ce serait perdue il faudrait que la
dame noire se sacrifie contre la tour et
là les blancs en a
jeu suffisant pour gagner la partie à ce
niveau là évidemment les grands maîtres
ne continue pas là la partie tout à fait
donc donc ce qu'est ce qui est assez
impressionnant ce qui m'a impressionné
dans cette partie c'est qu'après euros
après le 20e coup il semblerait qu adam
s'en soit sorti voyez il avait position
symétrique juste un cavalier contre un
fou et il n'a jamais réussi à se
regrouper à 10 ans absent claire
allienne flec ont effectivement il n'est
jamais il n'a jamais réussi à s'en
sortir il n'a jamais réussi à
remobiliser ses pièces correctement et
kasma fln a pas laissé le choix vont
être con qu avec très peu de moyens on
peut arriver à créer des menaces très
très forte
oui et donc kasparov gagne la partie et
le tournoi et le tournoi alors voilà
jean kaspar organes tournoi après on
peut se poser la question
là il est sûr de gagner tant elle a posé
la question se pose même pas puisqu'il a
déjà un point d'avancé un demi point
d'avancé au départ dont qui gagne donc
même si sur of marriage gagne la partie
évidemment celui qui gagne en a toujours
un demi point de retard dans
l'expérience et tranquille il a gagné le
tournoi il a encore fait démonstration
superbe sur sarajevo puisqu'il domine
complètement le tournoi derrière chiron
fait bas relief n'arrive pas je vois là
n'arrivent pas à se départager
je crois que shirov a quand même joué à
fond la partie mais dont qu'il n'en
sorte que la nul donc ils terminent tous
les deux deuxièmes ex-aequo mais à un
point du premier ce qui est toujours un
écart ce qui est énorme
la forme oui tout à fait normalement
dans les tournois
quand on gagne avec un de mes points
d'avancé déjà exceptionnel normalement
les premiers ont tendance à être premier
ex-aequo un nu points d'avance c'est
déjà très bien
un point d'avancé et c'est de la
domination complète du temps alors sur
cette dernière partie donc morose et
beach gagne contre topalov sans tarder
dernière ronde short et imane font
partie nulle et sokolow et peter l'écho
font partie nulle donc on a un
classement final
qu'on peut qu'on peut rappeler donc
premier kasparov
avec 7 points sur 9 deuxième à égalité
donc si rohff et bas relief avec donc
six points six points sur neuf
quatrième donc la révélation de l'année
qui confirme bien ce statut il n'est pas
là par hasard ils arrivent à tenir un
très joli tournoi avec cinq points et
demi sur neuf c'est toujours au dessus
de la moyenne
faut noter que résultats moyens à ce
tournant est déjà très bon puisque pau
et demi sur neuf
on a les meilleurs joueurs du monde donc
on fait partie du gotha nombreuses et
beach effectivement avec +2 c'est à dire
les quatre victoires et deux défaites
fait une très belle prestation pour sa
première dans notre note ce niveau là
c'est vraiment exceptionnel c'est donc
c'est bien alors on verra la suivante on
attend la suivante et où les joueurs se
seront habitués un poisson style parce
qu'elles aillent donc encore réussi à
surprendre donc la prochaine prestation
de rosé beach sera tout aussi
intéressante que celle là à suivre ont
planté mon registre est jeune et puis je
crois qu'il a 21 ans 21 ans je crois
voilà donc nuire aux 5
adams qui fait quand même un joli
tournoi avec donc cinq points on peut
rappeler qu adam sortait d'une très
belle victoire à dos hermanas où il ya
le tournoi devant notamment
il y avait un atelier karpov il y avait
cramique il y avait
à nantes qui a fait un très mauvais
tournoi d'ailleurs terminé avant-dernier
je crois jeudi paul gaillat judit polgar
aussi donc on avait commenté d'ailleurs
la partie polgar contre adams et c'était
le fameux justement gambie marshall
d'adams numéro 6 l'écho qui fait tourner
on a des moyens et fait quatre points et
demi sur neuf ce qui est quand même une
jolie performance je vous rappelle que
peter l'écho nous a donné une interview
la semaine dernière en direct sur
diagonale depuis sarajevo donc je vous
invite à visionner si vous ne l'avez pas
déjà fait cette précédente émission
évidemment que vous retrouverez dans nos
archives avec donc l'interview en direct
de sarajevo de peter l'écho pendant ce
tournoi et nous a fait une très belle
analyse à la fois de son jeu mais aussi
des autres concurrents puisqu'il a
commenté fameux rosé vite il a commenté
kasparov il a commenté un peu tout le
tournoi c'est oui c'était c'est toujours
comme il est sur place il a forcément
des avis très très intéressant ayant
plus comme il est très fort il a
toujours des choses intéressantes à dire
oui donc c'était une interview assez
vraiment intéressante à à écouter et à
regarder tout à fait donc
donc voilà peter l'epo ensuite donc mais
topalov avec 4.1
ensuite on retrouve short numéro 8 il
faut rappeler que je sorte avec 3 points
donc mauvais tournant pour short frappé
qu'il remplace et chroniques qui était
qui avait déclaré forfait
donc je sorte remplacé kramnik un petit
peu au pied levé donc pas vraiment
préparé pour ce tournoi
il faut rappeler que short et quand même
numéro 11 mondiale nigel short fait deux
anglais dans les meilleurs joueurs du
monde
ce qui place l'angleterre comme on le
sait dans les meilleures nations
mondiales ne vienne yvan sokolov qui est
qu'elle crée la surprise avec andy
puisqu'il avait battu kasparov seule
défaite de kasparov cette année oui oui
et qui là ne confirme pas finalement
bons résultats 2 et candy son résultat
avait une aile et loyal et l'excellence
et le local de l'épreuve et a fait donc
ici malgré son public il n'a pas réussi
à imposer son style un peu particulier
bon il y signe un tournoi à mauvais mais
il faut bien des il faut bien des
perdants faut bien surtout quand il ya
des cas espérons le tourner évidemment
et 10e timan le hollandais qui fait une
prestation en demi teinte le fameux aux
landais volant à 2670 c'est l'eau et qui
fait un point et demi
voilà donc pas très bon tournoi pour le
fameux le sympathique
yann timan qui est depuis sur les
circuits depuis des années et des années
qui était d'ailleurs finaliste du
championnat du monde contre carpeaux oui
exact timan à une très très longue
carrière de joueur d'échecs derrière lui
il a il a gagné les plus grand tournoi
du monde
je pense qu'il a été troisième joueur
mondial à un moment dans sa carrière
donc timan a vraiment fait il a vraiment
été très impressionnant mais il est un
peu sur la sur le déclin c'est normal il
est plus il est plus si jeune que ça
maintenant il se consacre en plus
beaucoup l analyse et il s'occupe de la
revue un peu nos richesses - voilà il se
dit beaucoup de remarques et un moulin
de mondialement connu qui s'appelle
winch est ce qui est très intéressante
iliad native and voilà donc un peu on
peut rappeler que donc ce tournoi un
petit peu particulier c'est à sarajevo
mais on connaît ce qui s'est passé
en bosnie faut noter que kasparov a déjà
fait des prestations là bas il est déjà
allé de son propre chef je crois donc
participé notamment joué pour
bénévolement je prends
pour le club de sarajevo et notamment
faire la coupe d'europe des clubs et il
est donc je crois qu'il est citoyen
d'honneur d'ailleurs je crois citoyen
d'honneur membre d'honneur je sais plus
citoyen d'honneur la ville de sarajevo
de toute façon c'est vrai que kasparov
et beaucoup pour pour la bosnie en
général notamment pour la ville de
salariés voilà donc
donc d'après les dires mêmes de peter
l'écho très très bonne ambiance
sarajevo où les organisateurs étaient
aux petits soins pour les joueurs donc
c'est sûrement un grand souvenir
un grand souvenir pour eux voilà donc ce
très beau tournoi de sarajevo et de très
belles parties est et de très grands
joueurs
voilà deux parties analysé sur des gones
avec donc la semaine dernière kasparov
short et cette semaine kasparov contre
contre adams alors on peut noter une
autre nouvelle cette semaine
donc eloi ce sont les oscars d échec
décernées donc c'est une tradition qui
avait été un peu abandonné je crois et
qui a été reprise depuis l'année
dernière où depuis deux ans je te
contredis pas en avant et ont donc les
les journalistes un peu comme en foot
d'ailleurs
elise est le joueur de l'année c'est le
ballon d'or voilà le ballon d'or fait
donc le l'échiquier dehors le cavalier
d'or je sais pas comment dire le fait
les oscars des échecs
voilà donc sur l'année 98
évidemment nous allons rappeler voilà on
rappelé on rappelle que kasparov n'a pas
joué en 98 ou très très peu et c'est
c'est donc numéro 1 des oscars c'est pas
vraiment une surprise
quatre-vingt dix-huit c'est le joueur
qui a gagné le plus de tournois de haut
niveau c'est viswanathan anand l'indien
numéro deux mondial oui c'est
extraordinaire il a fait une saison voit
enfin une année mais vraiment
époustouflante où il craignant
pratiquement tous les tournois où jouer
voilà donc ce qui était vraiment
remarquable donc même le tournoi de
linares ou kasparov avait fait un
tournoi où il n'avait pas perdu deux
parties n'ayant d'ailleurs battu un nom
qui l'avait battu à nantes mais c'était
sa seule victoire
elle a fait une un gain et 8 nuls ou
quelque chose de faite je sais plus
exactement mais il avait gagné contre
alain en effet toutes les autres pays un
nul voilà il n'était pas tellement en
forme et d'ailleurs c'est après après ce
tournant il n'a plus joué
je crois donc deuxièmes de ces oscars
mais morose et vite
voilà donc qui effectivement a
impressionné le monde entier donc le
numéro deux au vote des journalistes
numéro 3 on retrouve kasparov numéro 4
kramnik numéro trois mondial numéro 5
shirov numéro 4 mondial lui aussi ce
karpov quand même oui enfin le saas et
les têtes de série on est obligé quand
même de les retrouver de toute façon
voilà même si dans dix ans qu'on
retrouve les qui finalement on retrouve
à la même dans ces oscars des échecs les
meilleurs joueurs du top 10 on trouve le
top 10 un petit peu numéro 7 vide l'air
numéro 8 donc ivantchouk adams en numéro
9 et 10 l'écho quand même un peter
l'écho donc qui fait qui a fait aussi
une belle années 80 juste un petit peu
son retour aussi sur la scène
internationale enfin son retour à 19 ans
si on peut parler de votre four voilà
donc sur ces oscars des échecs
voilà l'actualité prochaine au niveau
mondial et loi c'est le mois au mois de
juin il va se passer pas mal de choses
puisque l'on va avoir droit à un match
aller en espagne entre karpov et anand
sur les adventure c'est à dire les
joueurs vont s'affronter sur un match en
six parties avec l'aide chacun d'un
d'un programme des chèques en tête de
n'doye va revenir dans les ordinateurs
alors donc pour deux raisons le
l'ordinateur servira et pour la base de
données
dire que les joueurs pourront faire
référence à toutes leurs analyses à
toutes les parties existantes et pour le
module d'analysé donc en l'occurrence
donc ce qu'on connaît en général on dit
fritz qui est un peu le l'amusant fin de
ce qui généralise les logiciels des
chèques dont qu'ils ont eu zéro ils
auront ces deux éléments leur
disposition c'est à dire toute leur
analyse tout leur préparation donc sans
aucun risque d'erreur puisque tout sera
dans l'ordinateur est en même temps le
module l'analyse qui leur permettra de
voir plus loin
on sait d'où les et chaque avancée en
fait voilà donc ça c'est le c'est le
rendez vous de juin je crois que ça
démarre le 6 juin donc pas encore la
semaine prochaine
et donc ensuite en fin juin début
juillet il ya l'allemagne qui organise
autre très gros tournoi puisqu'il ya le
front forte classique avec kasparov et
karpov cramique et anand
oui mais très très beau plateau très
beau plateau de l'année dernière karpov
avait refusé à la dernière minute de
jouer oui parce qu'il n'était pas au
courant qu'à ce parc devait jouer et
il avait dit non non je n'étais pas au
courant je joue pas oui parce que les
conditions ne vais pas te les mêmes je
pense que quand karpov rencontre
kasparov il ya certaines conditions ces
doivent être remplies c'est peut-être
plus cher et peut-être certaines
conditions de jeu effectivement qui doit
être donc cette année apparemment notre
joueur ou un tr min donc on aura en fait
que les allemands avaient voulu faire la
dernière fois les ordinateurs de
francfort donc un très beau semi-rapide
tournoi fermé doublé ronde donc à voir
je pense que ça va être très intéressant
et sinon l'autre tendent en allemagne
c'est le truman dortmund voilà d'ornon
très très gros tournois aussi il ya
karpov qui joue donc là c'est des partis
classiques par partie classique il y
aura je crois tout le monde là-bas il ya
kramnik aussi un homme il ya les co il
ya donc un très très beau plateau aussi
à dortmund donc mais ça c'est en juillet
c'est un peu ma guitare et fait donc
appel
les prochains rendez vous voilà donc les
en espagne karpov contre allende avec
donc l'aide d'ordinateurs ensuite
frankfort et ensuite dortmund voilà les
trois gros tournant qui nous attendent
évidemment mais d'ici là on a aussi des
actualités françaises et notamment pour
a commenté peut-être la participation
prochaine au championnat du france en
août de joël lautier détiennent macro
les deux numéros enfin les deux plus
forts joueurs en france actuellement
c'est la première fois que je vais loti
va jouer le national la deuxième fois
c'est à 2 il avait déjà joué une fois à
rouen 86 métier toujours je me trompe
peut-être les dates il avait déjà
terminé troisième quand même il était
tout jeune il avait 13 ans 14 enclos ils
étaient très jeunes le niveau était
moins relevé à l'époque voilà donc mais
voilà pour l'actualité cette semaine
nous vous remercions de nous avoir
suivis pour cette émission et moi je te
dis donc la semaine prochaine
et bien la semaine prochaine et merci de
nous avoir suivis et à bientôt